creo que tenemos una idea bastante clara
de cómo una señal es transmitida a lo
largo de la neurona vimos que un par de
dendritas podrían ser esta y ésta y ésta
podrían excitarse o ser activadas y
cuando decimos que se activan es porque
algún tipo de canal se abre
probablemente sea este el canal excitado
ese canal permite que los iones entren
en la célula o de hecho hay situaciones
donde los iones pueden ser expulsados de
la célula sería un caso inhibidor pero
tomemos el caso donde los iones entran
en la célula en un estado electro tónico
cambia la carga o el gradiente de
voltaje a través de la membrana y si los
efectos combinados del cambio en el
gradiente de voltaje son suficientes en
el cono axón y ccoo para llegar a ese
umbral
entonces los canales de sodio de aquí se
abrirán el sodio fluye al interior y
luego tenemos la situación donde el
voltaje se vuelve muy positivo los
canales de potasio se abren para
el voltaje nuevamente pero al volverse
muy positivo el efecto electro tónico
ocurre en la siguiente bomba de sodio y
se llega a la situación donde eso
permitirá a los iones de sodio entrar y
la señal sigue siendo transmitida ahora
la siguiente pregunta es qué pasa en las
uniones neurona neurona dijimos que ésta
dendrita es activada o se excita en la
mayoría de los casos se activa por otra
neurona pero podría ser algo más y por
aquí cuando este axón se activa debería
de estar excitado tanto a otra célula
podría ser una célula muscular o
probablemente en la mayoría de los casos
en el cuerpo humano está excitando otra
neurona
y como hace eso este es el botón
terminal del axón podría ser una tendría
de otra neurona justo aquí esta de aquí
es otra neurona no la estoy dibujando
muy bien pero creo que entendiste la
idea esta es otra neurona con su propio
axón su propia célula y esto activará a
la dendrita de aquí la pregunta es cómo
sucede eso como la señal se desplaza de
la acción de una neurona a la tendida de
la neurona de junto y de hecho no
siempre tienen que ir de la acción a la
bendita pero eso es lo más común podrías
ir de acción a acción de dendritas
dendrita acción a soma pero nos
enfocaremos en acción con dendrita esa
es la manera más tradicional en la que
las neuronas transmiten información de
una a la otra
hagamos una ampliación de esto esta
pequeña caja de aquí hagamos una
ampliación del botón terminal del axón
mejor hagamos un acercamiento a toda
esta área porque así también veremos la
dendrita de esta otra neurona para hacer
eso déjame dibujar el botón terminal
hacer eso déjame dibujar el botón
terminal digamos que el botón terminal
de la neurona se ve algo así estoy
haciendo una gran ampliación se ve algo
así
este es el pin
y ahora
y luego la siguiente bendita déjame
dibujarla aquí la bendita de la
siguiente neurona es de esta manera así
que hicimos una ampliación bastante
grande
esta es la d
t
pero no
este es el interior de la primera
neurona tenemos este potencial de acción
que sigue viajando a lo largo
habitualmente por aquí que equivaldría a
este lugar el potencial de acción hace
que el potencial eléctrico que el
potencial del voltaje a través de esta
membrana sean lo suficientemente
positivo para activar este canal de
sodio y creo que la dibuje demasiado
cerca este canal es este de aquí y
permite un flujo de sodio al interior de
la célula permite el flujo de sodio y
luego sucede lo demás tienes el potasio
que luego puede sacarlo pero cuando esto
entra esta carga positiva puede activar
otro canal y puede activar otro canal de
sodio si hay más canales de sodio hacia
esta dirección pero cerca del botón
terminal de la acción hay de hecho
canales de calcio los dibujaré en rosa
este es un canal de calcio este es un
canal de calcio que está
tradicionalmente cerrado este es un
canal de iones de calcio
el calcio tiene una carga de más 2
canal de iones de calcio tiende a estar
cerrado pero también está regulado por
voltaje cuando el voltaje es lo
suficientemente elevado es muy similar a
un canal de sodio regulado por voltaje
si el entorno se vuelve lo
suficientemente positivo cerca del canal
este se abrirá y cuando se abre permite
la entrada de iones de calcio en la
célula así que los iones de calcio con
su carga positiva de 2 más
fluyen al interior de la célula
ahora estarás diciendo porque están
fluyendo al interior de la célula iones
de calcio esto tiene carga positiva creí
que dijiste que la célula se está
volviendo positiva por todo el sodio
fluyendo al interior porque este calcio
fluiría al interior y la razón por la
cual quiere entrar es porque la célula
quiere así como bombea al exterior sodio
y al interior potasio la célula también
tiene bombas de iones de calcio y el
mecanismo es casi idéntico a lo que te
enseñe en la bomba de sodio potasio pero
solo involucra al calcio así que
literalmente tienes estas proteínas
que están a través de la membrana
esta es una víctima fosfolípido quizás
dibuje dos capas aquí solo para que
recuerdes que es una membrana bicapa
déjame dibujarla de esta manera se ve un
poco más realista aunque el dibujo
completo no es tan realista y ésta
también será una bicapa líquida
espero hayas entendido el concepto
déjame acabar de dibujarla solo para que
quede claro también estas bombas de
iones de calcio que también son
subgrupos de atp asas igual que como la
bomba sodio potasio les das un
atp
y el calcio se enlazará en otro lugar y
va a separar el fosfato de la atp
y esa será energía necesaria para
cambiar la conformación de esta proteína
a sacar al calcio y esencialmente lo que
sucede es que el calcio se enlazará y
luego se abrirá para que el calcio pueda
solo salir de la célula esta es como la
bomba sodio potasio pero es bueno saber
que en el estado de reposo tienes una
alta concentración de iones de calcio
aquí todo está regulado por el atp una
concentración mayor en el exterior que
en el interior y está controlada por
esas bombas de iones una vez que tienes
ese potencial de acción en lugar de
activar otro canal de sodio empieza a
activar los canales de calcio y estos
iones de calcio fluyen al interior del
botón terminal de este acción ahora
estos iones de calcio se unen a otras
proteínas y antes de seguir hablando de
esas proteínas tengamos en mente lo que
está sucediendo cerca de esta unión aquí
el lugar donde esté acción se encuentra
con esta bendita está es la sinapsis
esta es la
o podrías verlo como el punto de
contacto o el punto de comunicación o el
punto de conexión y esta neurona de aquí
es llamada la neurona presináptico
déjame escribirlo
pero nada
por qué
acá
esta es la nube
luego nada
pues sí
y cada neurona postsináptica y el
espacio entre las dos neuronas entre
este acción y esta dendrita esta es la
hendidura sináptica déjame escribir en
ti
ahora
knapp
y es un espacio muy pequeño y lo que
veremos en este vídeo is la sinapsis
química generalmente cuando la gente
habla de sinapsis se refiere a la
sinapsis química también hay sinapsis
eléctricas pero no quiero entrar en
detalles en esas esta es la más
tradicional que la gente menciona la
hendidura sináptica de una sinapsis
química es de aproximadamente 20
nanómetros la cual es muy pequeña si
piensas en el ancho promedio de una
célula es de puede ser de 10 a 100
micras estas 10 micras son 10 a la menos
6 metros
eso es 20 veces 10 a la menos 9 metros
es una distancia muy pequeña y tiene
sentido porque ve que tan grandes se ven
las células comparadas con esta pequeña
distancia es una distancia muy pequeña y
tienes en esta neurona pre sináptica
cerca del botón terminal
tienes vesículas y recuerda lo que son
las vesículas son miembros encapsulados
dentro de la célula tienes estas
vesículas también tienen su bicapa
fósforo
lipídica
suscita estás lipídicas son pequeñas
membranas tienes estas vesículas puedes
considerarlas como contenedores dibujaré
una más justo así y contienen estas
moléculas llamadas neurotransmisores y
dibujaré los neurotransmisores dentro de
ellas
probablemente has escuchado esa palabra
antes de hecho muchos medicamentos que
la gente usa para la depresión u otras
enfermedades relacionadas con nuestro
estado mental afectan a los
neurotransmisores y no entraré en
detalle en eso ahorita
pero contienen estos neurotransmisores y
cuando los canales de calcio son
regulados por voltaje cuando se vuelve
un poco más positivo se abren y el
calcio fluye al interior y el calcio se
enlaza a estas proteínas que tienen a
estas vesículas estas vesículas están
atracadas en la membrana pre sináptica a
este botón terminal del axón y estas
proteínas de hecho son conocidas por el
acrónimo es tener es un acrónimo pero es
también un buen nombre porque van a
enlazar las vesículas a esta membrana
como si fuera una trampa del lazo el
cual es el significado de la palabra es
tener en inglés esto es lo que estas
proteínas hacen y cuando estos iones de
calcio fluyen al interior se unen a
estas proteínas
se enlazan a estas proteínas y cambian
la conformación de las proteínas lo
suficiente para que estas proteínas
traigan a la vesícula más cerca a la
membrana y también separan a las dos
membranas y las membranas se unen déjame
hacer un acercamiento de eso solo para
dejar claro lo que está pasando después
de haberse unido esto de aquí es antes
de que el calcio entre después de
haberse unido al calcio a esas proteínas
snare luego la proteína es le llevará a
la vesícula super cerca de la membrana
pre sináptica esa es la vesícula y luego
la membrana pre sináptica se verá de
esta manera
esta manera y luego tienes a tus
proteínas snare y no la estoy dibujando
exactamente como se ve en la célula pero
te daré la idea de lo que está
sucediendo esencialmente en las
proteínas snare han acercado las cosas y
luego las han separado para que estas
dos membranas se unan y luego el
principal efecto secundario la razón por
la que todo esto sucede es que permite
verter esos neurotransmisores en la
hendidura sináptica esos
neurotransmisores que estaban dentro de
nuestra vesícula son liberados en la
hendidura sináptica este proceso de aquí
es una ex ositos y saliendo del
citoplasma podrías decir de la neurona
pre sináptica y estos neurotransmisores
probablemente escuchaste nombres
específicos de muchos de estos
serotonina dopamina epinefrina que es
también adrenalina esa es también una
hormona pero también actúa como
neurotransmisor
la norepinefrina es una hormona y un
neurotransmisor estos son nombres que
probablemente hayas escuchado antes pero
de todas maneras estos entran a la
hendidura sináptica y luego se unen a la
superficie de la membrana de la neurona
postsináptica oa esta bendita digamos
que se enlazan aquí aquí y aquí se
enlazan en proteínas especiales en estas
superficies de la membrana pero el
principal efecto de eso es que eso
activará canales de iones esta neurona
está excitado está dendrita cuando estos
neurotransmisores enlazan en esta
membrana quizás se abran canales de
sodio quizá eso ocasiona que un canal de
sodio se abra en lugar de estar regulado
por voltaje está regulado por
neurotransmisores esto ocasionará que un
canal de sodio se abra y luego el sodio
fluirá
y luego como dijimos antes si vamos al
original es conducir este se excitará y
se volviera un poco positivo y si es lo
suficientemente positivo va a
incrementar el potencial de manera
electrónica en este punto del cono axón
y ccoo y luego tenemos otra neurona en
este caso esta neurona será estimulada
eso es esencialmente como esto sucede de
hecho podría ser inhibidor podrías
imaginar que esto en lugar de activar un
canal de iones de sodio se activará un
canal de iones de potasio el gradiente
de concentración de los iones de potasio
querrá que vaya afuera de la célula
elementos con cargas positivas saldrán
de la célula
si es potasio
recuerda utilizo triángulos para el
potasio y entonces cargas positivas
salen de la célula si te acercarás más
al botón terminal se volvería menos
positivo y entonces sería incluso más
difícil que el potencial de acción
empiece porque necesitará un lugar más
positivo para llegar al umbral y espero
no te confunda cuando digo eso esta
conexión la manera en la que la
describir primero es emocionante cuando
esto se excita de un potencial de acción
el calcio fluye al interior hace que
estas vesículas saquen su contenido en
la hendidura sináptica y eso hará que
otros canales se abran quizá canales de
sodio y eso estimulará a esta neurona
pero si hace que los canales de potasio
se abran entonces lo va a inhibir y así
es como estas sinapsis francamente
funciona
hay billones de sinapsis la mejor
estimación de cuántas sinapsis hay en la
corteza cerebral de los seres humanos es
de 100
vi
yo mes
y la razón por la cual podemos tener
tantas es porque una neurona puede de
hecho crear muchas muchas muchas
sinapsis puedes imaginar si esto es el
dibujo original de la célula tendrás una
sinapsis aquí otra aquí otra allá
podrías tener cientos o miles de
sinapsis yendo hacia una célula o
saliendo de una esto podría ser una
sinapsis con una neurona otra y otra y
otra
tienes muchas muchas muchas conexiones y
entonces las sinapsis son realmente lo
que nos da la complejidad de lo que
probablemente nos hace funcionar en
términos de mente humana pero de todas
maneras espero encuentres esto útil